There has been a slippery slope
of people who are trying to be pro Palestinian
and they have slipped down a lot of like very traditional,
very classic anti Semitic tropes
and have hip hopped over the line into anti Semitism.
And when speaking with people who are outside of the Jewish community,
I realize like
how little people are actually well versed in anti Semitism
and how long it's been going on.
And in some of the classic tropes of anti Semitism,
one of the ones I see the most is that the Jews rule the world
or run the world.
Number one, that's simply not true.
There is less than 2% of the population is Jewish.
We don't run the world.
There is no like network of connected Jewish puppet masters.
That's anti Semitism,
that's conspiracy theory and that's not true.
There's also this sort of idea that
because you see Jewish people in the world of finance
or the world of entertainment,
that somehow we have like manipulated our way into that,
when in fact it comes from like historical anti semitism.
Jewish people were seen as second class citizens
in most of the communities they existed in,
even all the way back to like the Middle Ages and the Renaissance
and beyond that as well.
Jews regularly had to live in ghettos and had
what jobs and ways they can make money
regulated by the local government.
So banking is one of the things that Jews Were allowed to do.
Specifically, the most I know about this is in Renaissance Italy,
where there is an actually really old Jewish population.
But they were consigned to live in ghettos.
They could only work in a few professions,
finance and banking being one of them.
Because the leaders,
the Christian leaders at the time and still until this day,
find banking and working with money to be like
a lower class and a dirty profession.
So Jews were allowed to do it.
Which is why still today,
you'll see a lot of Jewish last names as banks,
because this has been going on for hundreds of years.
Same exact thing with the entertainment industry.
Everyone's talking about how Hollywood is so Inter dispersed with.
With the Jewish culture.
And that's because being an actor,
being an entertainer was a low class and a not appreciated job.
A lot of Hollywood,
a lot of entertainment was built by Jewish populations
because it was considered dirty and low class.
Like, this was not the world of celebrity that it,
you know, that we know now.
So when people point to these things,
they will will.
Jews aren't being oppressed
because they run banks and their Hollywood producers.
It's literally looking at a way that we found to have success
in the very narrow aspects that we were given
because of anti Semitism and because of prejudice.
And now punishing us for it,
punishing us for having made something of ourselves.
In these industries
that were the only industries we were allowed to do.
It's like someone sets the rules in order to make us fail,
and when we don't,
we're punished for it.